et certains même redoutaient que les
Juifs
jusqu'à leur dispersés
mais qui était resté ce qu'ils avaient
été de tout temps c'est à dire
un peu plus d'élite
sur de lui-même
et de
mesdames messieurs je me félicite de
vous voir
sur les sujets qui en valent la peine
et qui sont d'ailleurs présent à tous
nos esprits
je suis prêt à répondre aux questions
que vous voudrez bien me poser je vous
en prie
général
j'ai voulu vous demander si vu la
dégradation récente la niveau sternin
vous estimez que l'Angleterre est
maintenant plus adapté à entrer dans le
marché commun puis à six mois lors de
votre dernière conférence de presse
qui ont vendu des livres sterling et
ceux qui maintenant achètent de l'or ont
perdu confiance dans le système
monétaire mondial en partie à la suite
des critiques que vous leur avez adressé
ne craignez-vous pas
[Musique]
ne craignez-vous pas que cette perte de
confiance
puisse contribuer à une crise économique
mondiale qui causerait des souffrances
terribles
de Ville de Montréal vous avez prononcé
4 mots qui ont fait le tour du monde et
soulevez un flot de réaction passionné
et contradictoire aussi bien en France
que dans tout le Canada quatre mois
après cet événement est-ce que vous
auriez quelques réflexions ajoutées à
celles que vous avez faite votre retour
du Québec et d'autre part pourriez-vous
nous dire
quels sont à vos yeux les grands
objectifs de la coopération
franco-québecoise qui connaît depuis
quelques temps un développement accéléré
monsieur le Président les rapports qui
sont établis depuis les dernières
élections législatives entre le
gouvernement et le Parlement font-ils
apparaître à votre avis une modification
l'évolution profonde dans le
fonctionnement et l'esprit même des
institutions
quand vous appelez c'est l'importance
des valeurs un peu d'attacher à celui-ci
embêter auriez-vous dit arrêtez de la
venue
[Musique]
c'est à vous pour commencer si vous
permettez que je veux répondre
remarquer que la nudité pour une belle
créature
c'est
assez naturel et pour ceux qui
l'entourent c'est assez satisfaisant
mais quelle quatrie que j'éprouve pour
l'Angleterre je n'ai jamais dit ça à son
sujet ça fait partie de ces propos qu'on
le porte sur mon compte il paraît même
qu'on en fait des livres et qui
et qui ne répondent que de loin à ma
pensée et à mes propos
s'il y a d'autres questions
ne vous semble-t-il pas que les
vacuation anticipées de mercel Kebir
constituent un danger pour la sécurité
de la France
des petites questions première question
vous avez parlé plusieurs membres de
votre gouvernement aussi sur
l'association de la rampêta du Marché
Commun comprend bien souhaitable à son
assession complète pouvez-vous vous
donner des précisions sur
cette association et encore une autre
question s'il vous plaît dernièrement on
a beaucoup parlé de ce que beaucoup de
observateurs ont qualifié de un
événement politique
je parle de du livre de Monsieur Sevran
scruber les défis américain
deux personnalités de la vie française
comme Monsieur Giscard d'Estaing
Monsieur François Mitterrand on fait
face à cette question traversante
des filles américaines
de cette question dans un moment si
intéressant pour la construction
européenne pouvez-vous nous dire si vous
savez lu les livres et si oui
quel est votre avis sur le même
vous savez on ne fait pas de publicité
littéraire
Georges Broussine Radio Monte Carlo et
la politique ce matin en général au
cours de votre dernière conférence de
presse vous avez évoqué les grandes
mutations économiques dont la France est
l'objet ces mutations semblent
aujourd'hui provoquer des causer des
problèmes particulièrement difficiles
notamment dans le domaine de
l'agriculture comme paresse en témoigner
les récentes manifestations paysannes
pouvez-vous nous dire comment vous
envisagez quelle solution vous envisagez
pour ces problèmes économiques et
sociaux dans leur ensemble et pour ces
problèmes agricoles en particulier
au Moyen-Orient il y a six mois elle
s'est aussitôt terminée comme on sait
que pensez-vous de l'évolution de la
situation dans ce secteur depuis le mois
de juin dernier
cette vidéo de la vie française mon
général je reviens sur les problèmes
monétaires certains organes de la presse
anglo-saxonne accuse les autorités
françaises d'avoir contribué à la
dévaluation de la livre et
ultérieurement ou remous du marché de
l'or qu'en est-il exactement
en général lors de votre voyage en
Pologne vous avez à plusieurs reprises
évoqué le progrès le problème des
frontières et vous avez esquissé les
grandes lignes d'un règlement dans le
cadre d'une Europe du centre pouvez-vous
nous donner des indications plus
précises sur cette politique en général
une barbe le nouveau journal La
baissement des barrières douanières avec
le reste du monde prochainement et la
disparition des barrières douanières en
Europe pose des problèmes de mise en
condition la France vous paraît-elle en
état d'y faire face
en général
depuis quelques temps il est beaucoup
question de l'après gaullisme le Premier
ministre disait hier que ces
spéculations sur la disparition du
général de Gaulle était choquante mais
il n'y avait vous jamais pensé
mais ne n'y avez-vous jamais pensé
vous-même en général
fais de beaux rêves et les dernières
nouvelles
la tribune des Nations
mon général il est des questions qui
reviennent à chacune de vos conférences
de presse l'une d'entre elles est le
problème du conflit du Vietnam
pouvez-vous nous dire si vous considérez
qu'il y a eu une évolution de la
situation autour de ce problème depuis
votre dernière conférence de presse
belpora dernière nouvelle hôtel à vivre
monsieur le Président pourquoi
considérez-vous que l'État d'Israël soit
l'agresseur dans la guerre de 6 jours
alors que c'est le président Nasser qui
a fermé le détroit de tyran
bien voilà tout un ensemble de sujets ce
dont nous parlions à l'instant même et
qui sont les principaux sur lesquels je
vais m'efforcer de répondre
il y a naturellement notre politique
économique et sociale elle a d'ailleurs
quelques rapports et je sera amené à le
dire avec le système monétaire
international
il y a la question
du conflit d'Orient bien sûr
il y a la grande affaire du Québec
il y a tout ce qui se rapporte à
l'Angleterre
et en particulier au point de vue de sa
candidature au Marché commun
il y a ce qui a très à nos institutions
à notre régime à la façon dont il
fonctionne
et à ce qu'il peut être dans l'avenir
je crois que je n'ai rien oublié sinon
que j'ajoute ceux qu'on m'a demandé à
propos du voyage en Pologne de ce qui a
été dit et de ce que ça signifie
et bien nous allons répondre à ces
sujets en commençant si vous le voulez
bien parce qu'il concerne notre
politique économique et sociale sur quoi
je voudrais bien qu'on me répète les
questions qu'on me pose
mon général vous aviez dans votre
dernière conférence de presse évoqué les
mutations profondes de l'économie
française ces mutations paraissent
aujourd'hui provoquer des problèmes
particulièrement aigus notamment dans le
domaine de l'agriculture comme en
témoigne les récentes manifestations
agricoles pouvez-vous préciser les
solutions que vous envisagez pour ces
problèmes économiques et sociaux dans
leur ensemble et pour le problème de
l'agriculture en particulier
c'est une immense mutation que la France
est en train d'accomplir
une immense mutation économique et
sociale on a déjà dit ces bananes
cette mutation mais naturellement en
cause tous les intérêts tout est
structures toutes les habitudes
et de la inévitablement
toutes sortes
de réactions
de réclamation d'inquiétude
attiser bien entendu par toutes les
démagogies et d'autant plus politisée
que c'est l'État qui conduit l'évolution
lui seul le doigt
puisqu'il est en charge de l'intérêt
général et du destin du pays qui sont
les enjeux du changement
et lui seul le peu parce qu'il détient
les moyens légaux
financiers administratif tarifaire
diplomatique etc
qui sont nécessaires encore faut-il
qu'il applique son action
au facteurs essentiels du développement
sans la laisser se disperser au gré des
revendications
fragmentaires et qui sont épisodiques
et bien si on veut se faire une idée
dans son ensemble de la politique
économique financière sociale de la
France
il n'est que constaté
sur quel point
et de quelle façon
l'action publique a choisi de s'exercer
voici ce qu'il en est je vous le dis le
répéterai
certains de ne pas vous apprendre grand
chose
dans le domaine de l'industrie
le but à atteindre
étant qu'elle soit compétitive sans
aucune réserve à l'intérieur du marché
commun et largement à l'échelle du monde
poussé aux investissements
qui modernis ces équipements
encourager aider
à ces concentrations
et à ses meilleures méthodes de gestion
qui donnent à ces entreprises la
dimension et la puissance
favoriser ses exportations et ses
placements en dehors qui est tendent son
champ d'action
le fait est que depuis 8 ans
la production industrielle française
s'est accrue en moyenne
de 5 et demi pour cent par an
et que ces exportations
ont pour ainsi dire tripler
dans le domaine de l'agriculture
dont il s'agit qu'elle devienne une des
bases modernes de notre économie
déterminée ces exploitations
à vivre et à travailler non plus comme
autrefois
pour la simple subsistance des familles
qui les cultive
mais bien pour fournir vendre et acheter
précisément les produits qui peuvent les
rendre bénéficiaires encourager les
groupements
qui ont pour but
de réaliser à cette fin
d'organiser à cette fin les productions
les sélections les marchés
améliorer les structures
en agissant pour agrandir les trop
petites superficie
pour faciliter les retraites les
conversions les reconversions les
fusions
et pour remembrer les parcelles
le fait est que depuis 8 ans les directs
budgétaires à l'agriculture
a été multipliée par 10
on peut penser que suivant le rythme que
nous suivons
dans 10 ans
il restera en France quelque chose comme
un million 500 000 exploitations
agricoles
qui seront pour le moins rentable dans
leur grande majorité
qui emploie rond 10% de notre population
active au lieu de 55% à la fin du siècle
dernier
et qui tout de même produiront au total
trois fois plus qu'à cette époque là
dans le domaine des activités de pointe
qui entraînent et qui accélère la
production et la productivité activité
de pointe c'est-à-dire la recherche
l'atome l'électronique
l'aviation
l'espace
la télévision etc
c'est un fait que l'État depuis 8 ans
apporte une contribution massive
qui est cette année
huit fois plus grande qu'elle n'était en
et qu'il compte bien
la Croate dans l'avenir par priorité
naturellement il y a pas d'invention il
y a pas de calcul il y a pas de machine
qui puisse faire qu'à la base de
l'oeuvre humaine n'y est pas l'effort
humain pour le progrès des hommes il
faut les hommes
il les faut nombreux
car pour la France
toutes les possibilités de son
territoire
ne sont pas encore et doivent cependant
être mis en œuvre
c'est pourquoi
la croissance de notre peuple
doit être le premier de nos
investissements et c'est pourquoi
nous sommes conduits
incessamment
à prendre des mesures nouvelles pour
aider mieux et pour aider davantage à
l'épanouissement de nos jeunes familles
françaises
il faut également
que la population active
autant que possible
soit réparties entre les tâches
suivant les besoins de l'activité
nationale
et que chacun soit apte à son emploi
ce qui implique que ces temps des se
perfectionnent la formation
professionnelle celle des jeunes celle
des adultes
y compris les cadres et les dirigeants
et on sait
que les actions
publiques
exercées à cet égard emploi dix fois
plus de moyens
qu'on ne faisait il y a 8 ans
et ça implique aussi
que l'orientation
soit décidément organisée à l'intérieur
de l'éducation nationale ce qui va être
fait très bientôt
il faut encore que dans
la grande évolution très considérable et
inévitable toutes nos activités
le travail et les travailleurs
trouvent leur sécurité en dépit des
changements
d'emploi ou d'emplacement qui sont
nécessaires
ce à quoi l'aide publique
et maintenant
employé
sous toutes sortes de formes
soit à l'échelle de la nation soit à
l'échelle des régions
et il faut en fin
que dans les entreprises la
participation directe du personnel
au résultat au capital
et aux responsabilités
deviennent une des données de base de
l'économie française
très vaste transformation sociale dans
laquelle l'intéressement qui est
maintenant prescrit par la loi
constitue une importante étape
comme le bonheur le progrès ça n'existe
que par comparaison
dans notre terre industriel notre pays
est parti fort en retard par rapport à
certains autres au point de vue de son
développement
et pendant 100 ans il a subi les pires
épreuves nationales
et en outre il est
assez mal pourvu relativement
quand aux ressources naturelles
l'énergie les matières premières
espendants
le fait est que dans le monde libre
Europe Amérique agit Afrique
nous venons au troisième rang
pour ce qui est du de la valeur de notre
produit national brut il y a devant nous
à cet égard que les États-Unis et
l'Allemagne
nous venons au deuxième rang
après les Etats-Unis
mais avant l'Allemagne l'Angleterre
l'Italie au Japon etc
pour ce qui est de la valeur de ce
revenu national par tête d'habitants
ce qui donne aussi la mesure de notre
niveau de vie
lequel a augmenté en moyenne
depuis 8 ans
de 50%
le fait est que le taux d'accroissement
de notre productivité
est annuellement en moyenne de 4 et demi
pour cent ce qui est moins
qu'au Japon et en Italie
ce qui est au temps qu'en Allemagne mais
ce qui est plus qu'aux États-Unis et en
Grande-Bretagne
le fait est que mise à part l'Amérique
dans la population et 4 fois la nôtre
nous avons
plus de chercheurs 40
qu'il n'y en a dans aucun autre état
et que nos réalisations dans les
activités de pointe
atomes
réacteurs les plus avancés par exemple
réacteur à neutrons rapides
Caravelle
de ma Concorde
fusée diamant télévision en couleur etc
ont une notoriété universelle
et c'est pourquoi
nous envisageons sans alarme
la fin la disparition de toutes les
douanes à l'intérieur du marché commun
il est vrai
que nous nous trouvons en présence
d'une même mise américaine sur certaines
de nos entreprises
mais nous savons
que cela tient
pour une grande part
non pas tant à la supériorité organique
des États-Unis
qu'à l'inflation de l'art
qu'ils exportent chez les autres
sous le couvert du Gold échange standard
il est assez remarquable
que le total des déficits de la balance
des paiements américains depuis 8 ans
et précisément le total des
investissements américains dans les pays
de l'Europe
occidentale
il y a là évidemment un élément
extérieur
artificiel unilatéral
qui pèse sur notre patrimoine national
et on sait que la France souhaite qu'il
soit mis un terme à cet abus dans
l'intérêt de l'univers tout entier même
dans l'intérêt des États-Unis
pour lesquels le déficit des balances et
l'inflation sont déplorables comme ils
le sont pour tout le monde
il est possible
que les rafales qui se déchaînent à
présence en que la France y soit pour
rien
que les rafales qui se déchaînent à
présent
qui ont emporté
le taux de la livre et qui menace celui
du dollar
aboutit en fin de compte
au rétablissement
du système monétaire international
fondé sur l'immuabilité
l'impartialité
l'universalité
qui sont les privilèges de l'Europe
voilà dans leur ensemble quels sont nos
objectifs
et nos résultats quant à ce qui est
notre politique économique et notre
progression sociale
on dira que c'est de l'autosatisfaction
non
nous ne sommes pas complètement
satisfaits
et d'ailleurs pour une bonne raison
c'est que le caractère même de notre
temps c'est que quoi qu'on fasse
on peut faire plus et on peut faire
mieux
mais étant donné ce que nous réalisons
au milieu des nations
nous croyons que les leviers dont nous
nous servons sont ceux qui nous
conviennent le mieux
et c'est leviers sont la libre
entreprise
qui ne doit pas être un rempart pour le
polymobilisme mais qui doit être au
contraire une basse pour l'élan pour le
risque pour le développement
la concurrence internationale qui exige
le perfectionnement
et la direction pour ne pas dire le
dirigisme
qui choisit
les buts et les chemins aménagent les
moyens et harmoniser les efforts
c'est pourquoi le plan
dans lequel sont périodiquement fixés et
accorder les conditions de notre progrès
est devenu chez nous une institution
capital
nous allons passer à l'Orient si vous
voulez bien on avait posé des questions
sur le conflit actuel et je suis prêt à
y répondre
la guerre ayant éclaté au Moyen-Orient
il y a six mois elle s'est terminée
aussitôt ainsi que l'on sait que
pensez-vous mon général de l'évolution
de la situation dans ce secteur du monde
depuis juin dernier
et l'agresseur dans la guerre des Six
jours alors c'est le président Nasser
qui a fermé le détroit de terrain
l'établissement entre les deux guerres
mondiales car il faut remonter jusque là
l'établissement d'un foyer sioniste
en Palestine
et puis après la deuxième guerre
mondiale l'établissement d'un État
d'Israël
soulevait à l'époque
un certain nombre d'appréhension
on pouvait se demander en effet et on se
demandait même chez beaucoup de juifs
et si l'implantation de cette communauté
sur des terres qui avaient été acquises
dans les conditions
plus ou moins justifiables et au milieu
des peuples arabes qui lui sont
foncièrement hostiles
d'un
terminal friction et conflit
et certains même redoutaient que les
Juifs
jusqu'à leur dispersés
mais qui était resté ce qu'ils avaient
été de tout temps c'est à dire
un peu plus d'élite
sur de lui-même
et dominateur
n'en viennent une fois qui serait
rassemblée dans le site de son ancienne
grandeur
n’envielle a changé en ambition
ardente et conquérante
les souhaits très émouvants qu'il
formait depuis 19 siècles
l'an prochain à Jérusalem
en dépit du flot tantôt montant tantôt
descendant des malveillants
qu'il provoquait qu'il suscitait plus
exactement
dans certains pays il y a certaines
époques
un capital considérable d'intérêt et
même de sympathie
c'était formé en leur faveur
et surtout il faut bien le dire dans la
chrétienté
un capital
qui était
issu
de l'immense souvenir du testament
nourrit à toutes les sources d'une
magnifique liturgie
entretenu par la commissération
qu'inspirait leur antique malheur et que
poétiser chez nous la légende du Juif
errant
accrue
par les abominable persécutions qu'ils
avaient subi pendant la deuxième guerre
mondiale
et grossit
depuis qu'ils avaient retrouvé une
patrie
par les travaux constructeurs travaux
constructifs
et le courage de leur soldats
c'est pourquoi indépendamment des vastes
concours
en argent
en influence en propagande que les
Israéliens recevaient des milieux juifs
d'Amérique et d'Europe
beaucoup de pays dans la France
voyez avec satisfaction
l'établissement de leur état
sur le territoire que leur avait reconnu
les puissances
que lui avait reconnu les puissances
tout en désirant
qu'il parviennent en
usant d'un peu de modestie
à trouver avec ses voisins un modus
vivendi Pacifique
il faut dire que ces données
psychologiques avec quelque peu changé
depuis 1956
à la faveur de l'expédition
franco-britannique de Suez on avait vu
apparaître en effet
un État d'Israël guerrier et résolu à sa
grandir
et ensuite
l'action qu'il menait pour doubler sa
population
par l'immigration de nouveaux éléments
d'un état penser
que le territoire qu'il avait acquis ne
lui suffirait pas longtemps
et qu'il serait porté pour l'agrandir
à utiliser tout occasion qui se
présenterait
c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs la Cinquième
République
c'était dégagé vis-à-vis d'Israël des
liens spéciaux et très étroits
que le régime précédent avait noué avec
cet état
et la Cinquième République s'est
appliquée
au contraire
à favoriser la détente dans le
Moyen-Orient
bien sûr nous conservions avec le
gouvernement israélien des rapports
cordiaux
et même
lui fournissions pour sa défense
éventuelle les armements qu'il demandait
d'acheter
mais en même temps nous lui prodiguions
les avis de modération
notamment à propos des litiges qui
concernaient les eaux du Jourdain
ou bien des escargots qui opposaient
périodiquement les forces des deux côtés
enfin nous ne donnions pas notre aval à
son installation dans un quartier de
Jérusalem l'antise était emparée et nous
maintenir notre ambassade à Tel-Aviv
d'autre part
une fois mis un terme à la faire
algérienne nous avions repris
avec les peuples arabes d'Orient
la même politique d'amitié de
coopération qui avait été
pendant des siècles celle de la France
dans cette partie du monde
et dont la raison est le sentiment
font qu'elle doit être aujourd'hui une
des bases fondamentales de notre action
extérieure
bien entendu nous ne laissions pas
ignorer aux Arabes que pour nous l'État
d'Israël était un fait accompli
et que nous n'admetrions pas qu'il fut
détruit
de sorte que tout compris
on pouvait imaginer qu'un jour vient de
notre pays pourrait
aider directement
à ce qu'une paix réelle
fut conclue et garanti en Orient
pourvu qu'aucun drame nouveau
ne vint à le déchirer et là le drame est
venu
il avait été préparé
par
une tension très grave et constante
qui résultait du sort scandaleux
des réfugiés en Jordanie
et aussi des menaces de destruction
prodigués contre Israël
le 22 mai l'affaire d'acaba
fâcheusement créé par les gîtes
à l'étoffrir un prétexte à ceux qui
rêvaient dans des coudes
pour éviter les hostilités
la France avait dès le 24 mai proposé
aux trois autres grandes puissances
d'interdire
conjointement avec elle
à chacune des deux parties d'entamer le
combat
le
2 juin
le gouvernement français
avait officiellement déclaré
qui éventuellement il donnerait tort à
quiconque
entamerait le premier l'action des arts
et c'est ce qu'il répétait en toute
clarté à tous les États en cause c'est
ce que j'avais moi-même le 24 mai
déclaré à Monsieur Eban ministre des
Affaires étrangères d'Israël
que je voyais à Paris
si Israël est attaquée lui dit alors en
substance nous ne le laisserons pas
détruire
mais si vous attaquez
nous condamnerons votre initiative
certes malgré l'infériorité numérique de
votre population
étant donné que vous aide beaucoup mieux
organisé beaucoup plus rassemblés
beaucoup mieux armés que les Arabes
je ne doute pas qui est le cas échéant
vous remporteriez des succès militaires
mais ensuite
vous vous trouveriez engagé sur le
terrain
et au point de vue international dans
des difficultés grandissantes
d'autant plus que la guerre en Orient
peut pas manquer d'augmenter dans le
monde une tension déplorable
et d'avoir des conséquences très
malencontreuses pour beaucoup de pays si
bien que c'est à vous
devenu des conquérants
on sait que la voix de la France n'a pas
été entendue
Israël ayant attaqué
c'est emparé en six jours de combat des
objectifs
qu'il voulait atteindre
maintenant
il organise
sur les territoires qu'il a pris
l'occupation qui ne peut aller sans
oppression répression expulsion
et il s'y manifeste contre lui la
résistance
qu'à son tour il qualifie de terrorisme
il est vrai que
les deux belligérants observent pour le
moment d'une manière plus ou moins
précaire et irrégulière
le cessez le feu
prescrit par les Nations Unies mais il
est bien évident que le conflit n'est
que suspendu
et qui ne peut pas avoir de solution
sauf par la voix internationale
mais un règlement
dans cette voie à moins que les Nations
Unies ne déchirent de elles-mêmes leur
propre charte
un règlement
doit avoir pour base
l'évacuation des territoires qui ont été
pris par la force
la fin de toutes les gérance
et la reconnaissance de chacun des États
en cause par tous les autres
après quoi
par des décisions des Nations Unies avec
le la présence et la garantie de leur
force
il serait probablement possible
d'arrêter le tracé précis des frontières
les conditions de la vie et de la
sécurité des deux côtés
le sort des réfugiés et des minorités
et les modalités de la libre navigation
pour tous dans le golf d'Aqaba et dans
le canal de Suez
pour qu'un
règlement quelconque et notamment
celui-là puisse voir le jour
règlement auquel du reste suivant la
France devrait s'ajouter
un statut international pour Jérusalem
pour quinté de règlement puisse être mis
en œuvre
il faut naturellement il faudrait qu'il
lui l'accord des grandes puissances qui
entraînerait PSO facto celui des Nations
Unies
et l'accord voyez le jour la France et
d'avance disposer après été son concours
politique
économique et militaire pour que cet
accord soit effectivement appliqué
mais on ne voit pas comment
un accord quelconque pourrait naître
tant que l'un des plus grands des quatre
ne se sera pas dégagé de la guerre au
dieu qu'il mène ailleurs
car tout se tient dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui
sans le drame du Vietnam le conflit
entre Israël et les Arabes
ne serait pas devenu ce qu'il est
et si l'Asie du Sud-Est
voyait renaître la paix
l'Orient leur est bientôt retrouvé
à la faveur de la détente générale qui
suivrait un pari événement
nous allons parler du Québec qui m'avait
posé la question je vous en prie
président en juillet dernier du haut du
balcon d'hôtel de ville de Montréal vous
avez lancé quatre mots qui ont fait le
tour du monde il soulevaient un flot de
réaction passionné contradictoire
notamment en France et dans tout le
Canada 4 mois après cet événement
auriez-vous quelques réflexions ajoutées
à celles que vous avez faites à votre
retour du Québec d'autre part et surtout
pourriez-vous préciser qu'elles sont à
votre avis les grands objectifs de la
coopération franco-québecoise qui depuis
quelques temps comme un développement
accéléré
il y avait une autre question sur le
sujet
ce sont les Français qui
il y a plus de deux siècles et demi
jusqu'en 173
avec des couverts
peuplés
le Canada
quand il y a 204 ans le gouvernement
royal
qui avait essuyé de graves revers sur le
continent et qui de ce fait ne pouvait
soutenir en Amérique la guerre contre
l'Angleterre que de voir quitter la
place
60 000 Français étaient installés dans
le bassin du Saint-Laurent
et par la suite leur communauté
n'a reçu
que des éléments infimes nouveau venant
de la Communauté française de métropole
et cela
alors que
une migration de millions et de millions
de Britanniques
relayer récemment
par celle de nouveaux arrivants
se lave méditerranéen
scandinave
juif asiatique
que le gouvernement canadien d'Octave
déterminé à 100 bliciser
s'implantait sur tout le territoire
d'autre part les britannique qui
disposaient au Canada depuis cette
époque
[Musique]
pour amener les Canadiens les Français
canadiens a renoncé à eux-mêmes
et puis là-dessus c'était déclenché les
normes expansion des États-Unis
qui menaçaient dans l'outil l'économie
le caractère le langage du pays dans le
moule américain
et quant à la France
absorber qu'elle était par le multiple
guerre continentales
et
aussi par de nombreuses crises
politiques
elles se désintéressait de ses enfants
abandonnés et entretenait avec eux que
les rapports insignifiants tout semblait
donc concourir
à ce qu'il soit à la longue submerger
et bien
ce qu'il faut bien appeler un miracle
de vitalité d'énergie de fidélité
le fait est
qu'une nation française
morceau de notre peuple
se manifeste aujourd'hui au Canada
et prétend être reconnu et traité comme
tel
les 60 000 Français qui étaient restés
là-bas jadis
sont devenus plus de 6 millions
et il demeure français autant que jamais
au Québec même ils sont 4 millions et
demi c'est à dire l'immense majorité de
cette vaste province
pendant des générations
ces paysans d'origine
des petites gens qui cultivaient les
terres
ce sont magnifiquesment multipliés pour
tenir tête
au flots montant des envahisseurs
et au prix des forces inouïes
autour de leur pauvres prêtres
avec pour devises je me souviens
ils se sont acharnés et ils ont réussi à
garder leur langue leur tradition
leur religion
leur solidarité française
mais maintenant il se contente plus de
cette défensive passive
et comme toutes sortes d'autres peuples
du monde
ils prétendent de venir mettre de leur
destin
et d'autant plus ardemment maintenant
qu'il se sentent subordonné n'ont plus
seulement politiquement mais aussi
économiquement
et en effet étant donné la situation
rurale
isolée inférieur dans laquelle était
relégué la Communauté française
l'industrialisation s'est faite pour
ainsi dire par dessus elle
industrialisation qu'il a comme partout
domine la vie moderne
envoyer donc même au Québec les
anglo-saxons
fournir les capitaux les patrons les
directeurs les ingénieurs
formés à leur façon et pour le service
de leurs entreprises une grande partie
de la population active bref disposer
des ressources du pays
et cette prépondérance
conjuguée avec l'action qualifiée de
fédéral évidemment partial du
gouvernement canadien doit avoir
mettait dans une situation de plus en
plus inférieur
les Français
et
exposaient à des dangers croissants leur
langue leur substance leur caractère
c'est à quoi il se résignait pas du tout
il se résignait d'autant moins que
tardivement mais vigoureusement
il se mettait en mesure de conduire
eux-mêmes leur développement
par exemple la jeunesse
qui sort de leurs universités modernes
et de leur nouvelle école technique se
sont parfaitement capables de mettre en
œuvre les ressources les grandes
ressources de son propre pays et même
sans cesser d'être française de
participer à la découverte et à
l'exploitation de tout ce que contient
le reste du Canada
tout cela fait que
le mouvement
qui a saisi le mouvement la
franchissement qui a saisi le peuple
français d'Outre Atlantique
et tout à fait compréhensible
et aussi rien n'est plus naturel que
l'impulsion qui le porte à se tourner
vers la France
au cours de ces dernières années
il s'est formé au Québec
un puissant courant politique varié sans
doute dans ses expressions et unanime
sur la volonté des Français de prendre
en main leurs affaires
le fait est là
et bien entendu
il considère la mère patrie
non plus seulement comme un souvenir
très cher mais comme la nation
dont le sang le cœur l'esprit sont les
mêmes que les leurs
et dans la puissance nouvelle
et particulièrement apte à concourir à
leur progrès
alors que inversement leur réussite
pourrait procurer à la France
pour ce qui est de son progrès de son
rayonnement de son influence
un appui considérable
c'est ainsi que le fait que la langue
française perdra ou gagnera
la bataille au Canada pèsera lourd
sur la lutte qui est menée pour elle
d'un bout à l'autre du monde
c'est donc avec une grande joie et un
grand intérêt que le gouvernement de la
République a accueilli à Paris le
gouvernement du Québec dans la personne
de ses chefs successifs monsieur le sage
et Monsieur Daniel Johnson et a conclu
avec eux le premier accord d'action
commune
mais
il était évident que ces retrouvailles
de la France et du Canada français
devait être constaté
et célébrer solennellement sur place
c'est pourquoi Monsieur Daniel Johnson
me demanda de venir rendre visite au
Québec et c'est pourquoi je m'y rendu au
mois de juillet dernier
rien
ne peut donner l'idée
de ce que fut
la vague immense de foi et d'espérance
française qui souleva le peuple tout
entier au Québec
au passage du président de la République
de Québec jusqu'à Montréal sur les 250
km de la route longeant le Saint-Laurent
et que les Français Canadiens appellent
le chemin du roi parce que
jadis pendant des générations leur père
avait espéré qu'un jour
un chef de l'État français viendrait à
la parcourir
des millions des millions d'hommes de
femmes d'enfants
c'était rassemblés pour crier
passionnément vive la France
et ces millions
arborés les centaines et des centaines
de milliers de drapeaux tricolores et
drapeau du Québec à l'exclusion presque
totale de tout autre emblème
partout où je faisais halte ayant à mes
côtés le premier ministre du Québec est
telle ou telle de ses collègues et
accueillis par les élus locaux
c'est avec un enthousiasme unanime
que la foule accueillait les paroles que
je lui adressais pour exprimer trois
évidences
vous êtes des Français
ensuite en cette qualité
il vous faut être maître de vous-même
et enfin l'essor moderne du Québec vous
voulez qu'il soit le vôtre
après quoi tout le monde chantait la
Marseillaise
avec une ardeur indescriptible
à Montréal
la deuxième ville française du monde et
qui était le terme de mon parcours
le déferlement de la passion libératrice
était-elle
que la France
avait le devoir sacré
d'y répondre sans engage et
solennellement
c'est ce que je fis
[Musique]
en disant déclarant à la multitude
assemblée autour de l'hôtel de ville
que la France n'oublie pas ses enfants
du Canada
qu'elle les aime
qu'elle entend les soutenir dans leur
effort d'affranchissement et de progrès
et qu'en retour elle attend deux qui
l'aide dans le monde d'aujourd'hui et de
demain
et puis j'ai résumé le tout en criant
vive le Québec libre
ce qui porta au degré suprême la flamme
des résolutions
que le Québec soit libre
c'est en effet ce dont il s'agit
au point où sont les choses dans la
situation irréversible
qui a été démontré et accéléré par
l'esprit public
lors de mon passage
il est évident que le mouvement national
des Français canadiens
et aussi
l'équilibre et la paix du Canada tout
entier
et encore les relations de notre pays
avec les autres communautés de ce vaste
territoire
aime la conscience mondiale qui a été
maintenant éclairé
que cela exige que la question soit
résolue
il faut deux conditions
la première
c'est que
la première implique
un changement complet
quand à la structure canadienne
telle qu'elle résulte actuellement de
l'acte octroyer il y a 100 ans par la
reine d'Angleterre
et qui créa la fédération
cela aboutira à mon avis forcément
à l'avènement du Québec
au rang d'un État souverain et maître de
son existence nationale comme le son de
par le monde
tant et tant d'autres peuple tant et
tant d'autres états
qui ne sont pas
si valables ni même si peuplé
que le Québec
bien entendu cet état du Québec
aura librement et en égal à régler avec
le reste du Canada les modalités de leur
coopération
pour maîtriser et pour exploiter une
nature très difficile
sur l'immense étendues et aussi
pour faire face
à l'envahissement
les États-Unis
mais
on ne voit pas
comment les choses pourraient aboutir
autrement et du reste
si tel est leur aboutissement
il va de soi aussi que la France
est
avec un Canada qui prendrait cet aspect
qui prendrait ses caractères
d'entretenir avec son ensemble les
meilleures relations possibles
et la deuxième condition
pour que l'on dépend la solution de ce
grand problème
c'est que
la solidarité
de la Communauté française de parties
d'autres de l'Atlantique
s'organise
or à cet égard les choses sont en bonne
voie
et la prochaine arrivée ta prochaine
réunion à Paris
nous l'espérons
du gouvernement du Québec et du
gouvernement de la République
doit donner une plus forte impulsion
encore
à cette grande œuvre en françaises
essentielle en notre siècle
à cette œuvre devront d'ailleurs
participer dans les conditions qui
seront à déterminer
tous les Français du Canada qui ne
résident pas au Québec et qui sont un
million et demi
je pense en particulier à ces 250 000
Acadiens
qui sont implantés au nouveau-brassic
et qui ont gardé aussi à la France à sa
langue à son âme
une très émouvante fidélité
au fond nous tous français que nous
soyons du Canada ou bien de France
nous pouvons nous pouvons dire comme
Paul Valéry l'écrivait j'en ai pris note
quelques jours avant de mourir
il ne faut pas écrire et Paul Valéry que
périssent ce qui s'est fait
entend de siècles de recherche de
malheur et de grandeur et qui court de
si grands risques dans une époque où
domine la loi du plus grand nombre le
fait qu'il existe un Canada français
nous est un réconfort un élément
d'espoir inappréciable
ce Canada français affirme notre
présence sur le continent américain
il démonte ce que peuvent être vitalité
notre endurance notre valeur de travail
c'est à lui que nous devons transmettre
ce que nous avons de plus précieux notre
richesse spirituelle
malheureusement trop de Français non sur
le Canada que des idées bien vagues et
sommaires
et Paul Valéry concluait
ici
s'intégrer trop facilement
une critique de notre anciennement
assez pour lire tout ce que temps étant
de nos journaux publiés à l'occasion de
la visite que le général de Gaulle a
fait au Français du Canada
allons allons
pour eux aussi
pour un surtout il faut que la France
soit la France
on m'avait posé une question sur la
Pologne ce que j'avais pu dire dans la
reposer
moi en général lors de votre voyage en
Pologne vous avez à plusieurs reprises
évoqué le problème des frontières et
vous avez esquissé les grandes lignes de
règlements dans le cadre d'une Europe du
centre pouvez-vous nous donner des
indications plus précises sur cette
politique
laissez-moi vous dire que le voyage que
j'ai fait en Pologne au mois de
septembre
a mis en lumière dans une lumière
éclatante
deux évidences
la première c'est la vitalité
extraordinaire du peuple polonais
aujourd'hui plus grande qu'elle ne le
fut je crois jamais en dépit de tous les
épreuves qu'il a traversé
et la seconde c'est son amitié pour la
France
qui n'a jamais elle n'ont plus été plus
grande
me trouvant sur le territoire polonais
dans une région qui donne mon esprit ne
pourrait dans une peu plus être
contestée ne doit pas l'être
j'ai constaté ce qui était de 14
c'est-à-dire le caractère polonais
de la ville où je me trouve
je l'ai fait sans vouloir le moins du
monde
et obliger
nos amis de l'Allemagne
pour faire l'Europe qu'il faut faire
et qui comprend un Occident un centre et
un Orient
il faut que tout le monde soit respecté
y compris le grand peuple allemand
je ne crois pas
devoir en dire aujourd'hui davantage
et nous abordons mon cher ami
voulez-vous le redire
la grave affaire la grande affaire
de l'Angleterre
la dévoration de la livre ouvre des plus
grands perspectives pour l'entrée de
l'Angleterre dans le marché commun
quelqu'un m'avait demandé aussi quelque
chose je crois que ça suffit
depuis qu'il y a des hommes et puis
depuis qu'il y a des états
tout grand projet international
et nimbé de mythe séduisant c'est tout
naturel
parce qu'à l'origine de l'action il y a
toujours l'inspiration
et
ainsi pour l'unité de l'Europe
a commis serait beau et comme il serait
bon
que celle-ci puisse devenir un ensemble
fraternel et organisé
où chaque peuple
trouve sa prospérité et sa sécurité
ainsi en est-il aussi du monde
qu'il serait merveilleux que
disparaissent
toutes les différences de races de
langues idéologies de richesse
toutes les rivalités
toutes les frontières
qui divisent la terre depuis toujours
mais quoi
si doux que soit les rêves les réalités
sont là
et
suivant qu'on en tient compte ou non
la politique peut-être un art assez
fécond
ou bien une venue
c'est ainsi que l'idée
de joindre les îles Britanniques
à la communauté économique formée par
six étapes continentaux
soulève partout
des souhaits
qui sont idéalement très justifiés
mais qu'il s'agit de savoir
si cela pourrait être actuellement fait
sans déchirer sans briser
ce qui existe
or il se trouve que la Grande-Bretagne
avec une insistance et une rate vraiment
extraordinaire
et donc peut-être les derniers
événements monétaires éclairent un peu
certaines raisons
à proposer avait proposé
l'ouverture
sans délai
d'une négociation entre elles-mêmes et
les 6 en vue de son entrée dans le
marché commun
en même temps elle déclarait accepter
toutes les dispositions
qui régissent
la communauté des six ce qui semblait un
peu contradictoire avec la demande de
négociation car pourquoi négocierait-on
sur des clauses que l'on aurait d'avance
et entièrement accepté
en fait on assiste là
au cinquième acte d'une pièce
au cours de laquelle
les comportements très divers de
l'Angleterre
à l'égard du marché commun
c'était succédé
sans paraître se ressembler le premier
acte
ça avait été le refus de Londres
de participer à l'élaboration du traité
de Rome
dont autrement on pensait qui
n'aboutirait à rien
le deuxième acte manifesta lorsqu'il
était foncière de l'Angleterre
à l'égard de la communauté de la
construction européenne
dès que celle-ci parut se dessiner
et j'entends encore les sommes nations
je les dis me semble-t-il naguère les
sommations
qu'à Paris des juin 1958
l'adressait mon ami
monsieur Mac Millan
alors Premier ministre
qui comparait le marché commun avec le
blocus continental et qui naçait de lui
déclarer tout au moins la guerre des
tarifs
le troisième acte
ce fut une négociation menée à Bruxelles
par Monsieur morning pendant un an et
demi
négociations
destiné
à plier la communauté aux conditions de
l'Angleterre est terminée
quand la France fut observée à ses
partenaires
que il s'agissait
non pas de cela mais précisément de
l'inverse
le quatrième acte au commencement du
gouvernement de Monsieur Wilson
fut marqué par le désintéressement de
Londres à l'égard du marché commun
le maintien autour de la Grande-Bretagne
des 6 autres États européens formant la
zone de libre-échange et un grand effort
déployé pour resserrer les liens
intérieurs du commonweets
et maintenant ce jouet
le cinquième acte
alors pour lequel
la Grande-Bretagne posait cette fois sa
candidature
et afin qu'elle fut adoptée s'engager
dans les voies de toutes les promesses
et toutes les pressions imaginables
à vrai dire cette attitude
s'explique
à ces aisément le peuple anglais
discerne sans doute de plus en plus
clairement
que dans le grand mouvement qui emporte
le monde
devant les normes puissances des
États-Unis
c'est le grandissant de l'Union
soviétique c'est la renaissance des
continents
c'est le nouvel de la Chine
et compte tenu des orientations de plus
en plus centrifuge qui se font jour dans
le Commonwealth
ces structures et ses habitudes
dans ces activités et même sa
personnalité nationale
sont désormais en cause
et on ne meurt les graves difficultés
économiques
financières monétaire avec lesquels il
est au prix
le lui font sentir jour après jour de là
dans sa profondeur
une tendance à découvrir
un cadre fut-il européen
qui lui permettrait qu'il aiderait à
sauver
sauvegarder sa propre substance
qui lui permet de jouer encore un rôle
dirigeant
et qu'il allège d'une part de son
fardeau
il n'y a rien là
que le salutaire pour lui
et a échéance il n'y a rien là que de
satisfaisant pour l'Europe
à condition
que le peuple anglais
comme ceux auquel il souhaite se joindre
veuille et sache
ce contraindre lui-même au changement
fondamentaux
qui serait nécessaire
pour qu'il s'établisse dans son propre
équilibre
car c'est une modification une
transformation radicale
de la Grande-Bretagne qui s'impose
pour qu'elle puisse se joindre au
continentaux
c'est évident au point de vue politique
mais aujourd'hui pour ne parler que du
domaine économique
le rapport
qui a été adressé le 29 septembre par la
Commission de Bruxelles aussi
gouvernement
démontre avec la plus grande carte
que le marché commun actuel est
incompatible avec l'économie telle que
les de l'Angleterre
dont le déficit chronique de sa balance
des paiements
prouve
le déséquilibre permanent
et qui comporte
quand la production aux productions
aux sources d'approvisionnement à la
pratique du crédit aux conditions du
travail
des données
dans ce pays ne pourra les changer
sans modifier sa propre nature
marché commun incompatible aussi avec la
façon dont s'alimente les Anglais
tant par les produits de leur
agriculture subventionnées au plus haut
que par des vivres acheter à bon compte
partout dans le monde notamment dans le
commonweet
ce qui exclut
que Londres puisse réellement
accepter jamais les prélèvements prévus
par le règlement financier et qu'il lui
serait écrasant
marcher comme un
incompatible encore avec les
restrictions apportées par l'Angleterre
à la sortie de chez elle des capitaux
lesquels au contraire circule librement
chez les six
marché commun incompatible avec l'état
du sterling
tel que l'on mise en lumière
de nouveau
la dévaluation
ainsi que les empreintes qui l'ont
précédé et qu'il accompagne
l'état du sterling
aussi
qui se conjuguant avec le caractère
de la monnaie de monnaie internationale
qui est celui de la livre
et les énormes créances extérieures qui
pèsent sur elle
ne permettrait pas
qu'elle fasse partie actuellement
de la société
solide et solidaire et assurer ou se
réunit le franc le marc la lire le franc
belge et le florin
dans ces conditions
à quoi pourrait aboutir
ce qu'on appelle l'entrée de
l'Angleterre dans le marché commun
et
si on voulait malgré tout l'imposer
ce serait évidemment
l'éclatement d'une communauté qui a été
bâti et qui fonctionne
suivant des règles qui ne supportent pas
une aussi monumentale exception
certes
et en outre je dois ajouter qu'il
supporterait pas non plus qu'on
introduise parmi ces membres principaux
un état
qui
précisément
par son sa monnaie
par son économie
par sa politique
ne fait pas partie
actuellement de l'Europe telle que nous
avons commencé à la bâtir
faire entrer l'Angleterre
et par conséquent engagé maintenant
une négociation
à cet effet
ce serait pour les 6
étant donné que tout le monde sait de
quoi il retourne
ce serait pour les 6
donner d'avance leur consentement à tous
les artifices délais et faux semblant
qui tendrait
à dissimuler la destruction d'un édifice
qui a été bâti au prix de tant de peine
et au milieu de temps d'espoir
il est vrai que tout en reconnaissant
l'impossibilité
de faire entrer
l'Angleterre d'aujourd'hui dans le
marché commun tel qu'il existe
on peut vouloir tout de même
sacrifier celui-ci un accord avec celle
là
théoriquement en effet
le système économique
qui est actuellement pratiquée par les 6
n'est pas nécessairement
le seul que pourrait pratiquer l'Europe
on peut
imaginer
par exemple
une zone de libre-échange s'étendant à
tout l'Occident de notre continent
on peut imaginer aussi un espèce de
traité multilatéral
du genre de suit qui sortira du Kennedy
Rand
et réglant entre 10 12 15 hectares
leur contingent
et leur tarifs
réciproque et respectifs
mais dans un cas comme dans l'autre
il faudrait d'abord abolir la communauté
et disperser ses institutions
et je dis que cela
la France ne demande certainement pas
pourtant
si tel ou tel de ses partenaires
comme après tout c'est leur droit
en faisait la proposition
elle examinerait avec les autres
signataires du traité de Rome
mais
ce qu'elle ne peut faire
c'est entrée actuellement avec les
Britanniques et leurs associés
dans une négociation
qui conduirait à détruire
la construction européenne à laquelle
elle fait partie
et puis ce ne serait pas là du tout le
chemin qui pourrait conduire
à construire une Europe à ce que
l'Europe se construit par elle-même et
pour elle-même
de manière
un être pas sous la dépendance
d'un système économique monétaire
politique
qui lui est étranger
pour que l'Europe
puisse
faire équilibre
alimente puissance des États-Unis il lui
faut non pas du tout affaiblir
mais au contraire resserrer
les liens et les règles de la communauté
certes ceux qui comme moi
ont prouvé par leurs actes
l'attachement
le respect
qu'il porte à l'Angleterre
souhaite vivement l'avoir un jour choisi
et accomplir l'immense effort qu'il a
transformerait
certes pour lui faciliter les choses la
France est toute disposée
à entrer dans quelques rangement
qui joue le nom l'association ou sous un
autre
favoriserait dès à présent les échanges
commerciaux entre les continentaux d'une
part les Britanniques les Scandinaves et
les Irlandais d'autre part
certes
ce n'est pas à Paris qu'on ignore
l'évolution psychologique qui paraissent
se dessiner chez nos amis outre-manches
ou qu'on méconnaise le mérite
de certaines mesures qu'ils avaient déjà
prises et d'autres qu'il projette de
prendre
dans le sens
de l'équilibre leur équilibre de dents
et de leur indépendance au dehors
mais
pour que les îles britanniques
puissent réellement s'amarrer au
continent
c'est encore une très vaste et très
profonde mutation qu'il s'agit
tout dépend donc
non pas du tout d'une négociation
qui serait pour les six
une marche à l'abandon
selon le glas de leur communauté
mais bien
de la volonté et de l'action
du grand peuple anglais
qui ferait de lui
un des piliers
de l'Europe européenne
on m'a demandé ce que ce serait que la
frigo
et bien c'est par là que nous allons
terminer
tout a toujours une fin et chacun se
termine
au moment ce n'est pas le cas
[Musique]
de toute façon
après de Gaulle ce peut être ce soir
ou dans 6 mois ou dans un an
ça peut être dans 5 ans
puisque c'est là le terme que fixe la
Constitution au mandat qui m'est confié
mais
si je voulais faire rire quelques-uns ou
en faire grogner d'autres
je dirais que ça peut aussi bien durer
encore 10 ans
franchement je ne le pense pas et sur ce
qui se passe actuellement alors je
demande à Monsieur Charpy de répéter la
question qui m'a posé je vais lui
répondre pour en finir
ce président les rapports qui se sont
établis entre le gouvernement et le
Parlement depuis les dernières élections
traduisent-ils à votre avis une
évolution dans le fonctionnement et
l'esprit même des institutions
après elle a stabilité
constitutionnelle dans laquelle la
France a été si longtemps plongée
nous avons eu faut toujours le dire 17
régimes en l'espace de 177 ans
après la crise gouvernementale
permanente
sous le régime parlementaire
sous la Troisième République de 1920 à
47 ministères en 20 ans et sous la
Quatrième de 1946 à 1958
24 ministères en 12 ans
après
la faillite des parties
et talents au long des années
quelques fûts souvent la valeur des
hommes
son impuissance à régler les très grands
et d'ailleurs très difficile problème
que nous impose notre époque
faisant de notre pays ce qu'on appelait
l'homme malade de l'Europe
et ses fondre en 1940
dans le drame de la guerre étrangère et
du désastre
et en 1958 au bord de la guerre civile
et de la faillite
il est arrivé que le peuple français sur
la proposition que je lui ai adressée
à par un vote massif
à une majorité immense
dotée la République d'institutions
qui sont solides
et adaptés à notre temps et de fait
depuis presque 10 ans bientôt 10 ans
la République française
au lieu
d'offrir comme autrefois un spectacle
permanent
d'impuissance de ses pouvoirs
donne au contraire un exemple qui est
partout connu de solidité de continuité
d'efficacité
grâce à quoi
et l'obtient dans les domaines
essentiels qui s'appelle le progrès la
dépendance la paix
les résultats
dans l'univers considère qu'ils sont
probants
mis à part les partisans
personne ne doute
que si aucun drame mondial devient tout
mettre en cause pendant quelques lustres
la Cinquième République
assurera à la France les meilleures
chances possibles de prospérité de
puissance et le rayonnement et que si la
tempête se déchaînait à nouveau sur la
terre
elle seule
serait en mesure
d'assumer le destin du pays
or chaque insert que l'élément capital
de ces institutions là
c'est l'attribution au chef de l'État
élu par le peuple
des moyens et de la charge
de représenter de faire valoir aux
besoins d'imposer
par-dessus toutes les tendances
particulières et momentanées l'intérêt
supérieur et permanent de la nation
et chacun sait qu'à fin de faire en
sorte que la politique
soit conforme à ce qui est essentiel
c'est à lui
qu'il appartient de choisir le
gouvernement c'est celui-là
de n'en arrêter la composition
et dans présider les réunions
et bien entendu chez cette clé de vous
l'édifice
que voudrais briser
ou bien les partisans de toutes origines
qui bien qu'il prétendent le contraire
veulent à l'assemblement
faire du pouvoir
l'enjeu de leurs ambitions et de leur
combinaison ou bien les conjurer de
l'entreprise totalitaire qui vise à
établir sur la France son écrasant des
mornes dictatures
et chacun sait enfin
que si
la défaillance du président
par rapport à ses obligations
venez jamais à ouvrir la brèche à ses
assaillants
la confusion politique et sociale la
dégradation économique
financière monétaire la baisse mon
internationale qui en fait les
conséquences
conduiraient inévitablement
à placer la France sous la coupe
de l'une ou de l'autre
des deux principales puissances
étrangères
cependant
on peut penser
que la situation actuelle
dans laquelle pour les milieux
spécialisés
ils se montrent encore
pas mal de parties contre les
institutions
cette situation ne se perpétuera pas
à mesure que dur que durera la Cinquième
République
on verra à la machine mange des citoyens
se désintéresser décidément de la
querelle vaine d'ailleurs fait un régime
qu'elle a adopté
ou qu'elle soit coutume fort bien
et dont elle estime
la dignité la solidité et l'efficacité
quelque soit les contestations du moment
on peut même penser que corrélativement
à cette position de plus en plus adoptée
par l'opinion
toute conjoncture parlementaire sa
commodra décidément de la séparation des
pouvoirs
séparation effective des pouvoirs
dont les textes
et la pratique ne permettent pas qu'on y
contreviennent
bref
un jour viendra sans doute
ou notre Constitution avec tout ce qui
est implique
nous sera devenu politiquement
comme notre second nature
de toute façon et quoi qu'il arrive
il appartient au président de la
République au chef de l'État de
maintenir les institutions dans leur
esprit dans leur terme
et d'orienter la politique de la France
pour tout le temps où il est et où il
est seul
le mandataire du peuple français tout
entier
c'est d'ailleurs je le crois bien
ce qu'on voulut
manifester ardemment et solennellement
ceux qui se sont réunis à Lille
tandis que leurs assistes travaillaient
adapter
aux conditions qui vont changer
nos conceptions
et nos inspirations
mesdames Messieurs Je t'aime
[Musique]